ryan reynolds and blake wallaby uh took
over the red carpet at last night's
world premiere of ryan's latest film the
adam project and i mean can we just talk
about this dress this versace dress she
looked absolutely gorgeous so good i was
just talking to my sister last night
she's like boy like blake always looks
good don't get me wrong but i feel like
recently she is just glowing on red
carpets i mean the pastels yup give me
all the spring feels i love it she also
arrived wearing a long denim jacket
draped over her shoulders
i think it looked really cool i really
like that i've worn that with jeans
before well one of our producers uh jody
didn't like it he didn't like the jacket
i don't think he was a fan there was
kind of a joke that maybe she should be
wearing a hat with it but because i
think it's it's you know jean jacket you
think um
not as fancy and she's wearing this
gorgeous dress but if anyone's going to
pull it off it's like lively yeah but
she has the collar i know oh god they
look so good together
i'm just taking a moment and taking this
in right now because i know they're so
hot together so hot oh my goodness i
want to be them that is just beauty
right there i know and they both seem so
nice this seems so nice i love it now in
the most uh while in the midst of
promoting his latest film ryan recently
opened up about his mental health
struggles and dealing with anxiety
throughout his entire life yeah in a new
interview on cbs sunday morning ryan
recalled one particular incident when he
felt extremely nervous before a 2015
appearance on late night with david
letterman despite having been on the
show several times before
i've had anxiety
my whole life really
and
you know it's there's a i feel like i
have two parts of my personality that
one takes over when that happens when i
would go out on like letterman back in
the day
i would always be nervous but i remember
i'd be standing backstage before the
curtain would open and i would i would
think to myself i'm gonna die i'm
literally gonna die here or the
curtain's gonna open and i'm just gonna
be i'm just gonna be a symphony of vomit
just like something horrible is gonna
happen but as soon as that curtain opens
and this happens in my work a lot too
it's like this little guy takes over and
he's like i got this
you're cool ladies and gentlemen please
welcome ryan reynolds orion come on
[Applause] [Music]
i feel like my heart rate drop and my
breathing calm and i just kind of go out
and i'm this different person and it's
like i leave
that interview going god i'd love to be
that guy
wow
i look i know he's been open before yeah
a lot of struggles with mental health
but you know i think especially somebody
like ryan reynolds who always looks like
he's having the best time ever always
seems like he's in control so confident
to hear that is is really telling and
and i love that he's sharing that with
people now ryan also spoke openly about
his
childhood
growing up as the youngest of four boys
with a father who was a police officer
who ran a very tight household
i don't want to paint this picture that
it was this like horrible place to grow
up but it was very tense and just
because of your dad yeah my dad was a
very tense guy and you know i used to
sort of describe him as like a skin
covered landmine i attribute some of the
why i'm good at my job from that i'm
perceptive i watch carefully for danger
and you know as an adult that can really
come in handy
well you know talking about his dad and
we were talking about this earlier the
fact that you know he is reunited with
his dad after years of not really
talking to his father and yeah and blake
lively played a huge part in that she
really did now in the adam project uh
ryan stars as a time traveling pilot who
teams up with his younger self and his
late fathers played by mark ruffalo
which is absolutely amazing to
come terms with his past while saving
the future yeah and cheryl hickey
recently reunited with ryan face to face
at the toronto premiere so jealous of
her and of course we had to ask him what
advice he would give his younger self
i think i would try to be a little bit
more compassionate i've always been
pretty self-loathing that's sort of what
we tackle in the movie is that you think
when i meet my younger self i'm going to
be this sweet generous like caring
person but i'm actually just the
opposite i'm a kind of to them um so you
know if i saw my younger self i'd
probably be like hey you're gonna you
know you're gonna be like a certifiable
[ __ ] until you're about 35 years old
but then you're going to get it together
and then things are going to go really
really well yeah things are gonna be
okay yeah
i love that i don't know if you guys
noticed but he talked about being 35 and
that's when he finally got his life
together it's cause that's when he met
blake lively oh
i know i was watching the interview and
i was like they've been together 10
years he's 45 i was like oh gosh you
know what ryan is like he is the nicest
guy you'll ever meet one of the nicest
people see on the red carpet interviews
remember who you are he sometimes even
knows what your life is all about on
social media and he just has this
incredible energy and you know
it's interesting because i've been
watching will smith as well i know this
is another completely
different celebrity but it seems there
are celebrities going through a lot a
lot of transitions where there you seem
they're very happy but they're going
through so much personally and i think
that's a lot with a lot of comedians too
where i find like you know you go in
you're expecting them to be he's bigger
than life happy people yeah and then
always entertaining yeah so you know
it's interesting but him being so honest
and open and he's done so much for so
many hospitals and charities it's just
it feels good that he's talking about
and this movie is absolutely amazing i
highly recommend for everyone to watch
the adam project uh it's actually at the
end of the day a love letter to moms out
there oh
it is it is at the end of it it's also
about time travel and adventure and all
that but uh it just does feel good movie
and ryan is absolutely incredible
amazing so cheryl was telling me because
she has seen it as well and she saw me
on the show a few days ago that she
likes it better than a free guy and
everybody loved free guys she said she
got really emotional in this yeah
because it's a love letter tomorrow
i'm not good i want to hug my kids yeah
i don't know if it's better than the
friend free guy because i absolutely
love every guy i can't wait to see for
the second part and see if actually
because sean levy was also the director
of this one as well canadian director
exactly um but yeah i think him sharing
all these experiences is going to really
help other people i agree with you and
jeff saying this too you know i love
when male celebs specifically open up
about their struggles with anxiety and
depression because he says he too has
struggled with that so it's kind of you
know it's it's this other way like you
were just saying you know when actors we
think like their lives look perfect yeah
when they open up about that you're like
okay it's okay that i also
go through this do you ever have that
anxiousness before presenting or
performing or oh goodness yes yeah oh
it's oh boy i've had full-on
panic attacks uh specifically in another
job i had when i would have to uh do
interviews at
conventions and i'm in front of hundreds
of people i've been in front of
auditoriums before yeah and i literally
have no idea how i'm gonna do it i used
to call my mom a lot and then she would
be so panicked for me she would calm me
down but she's like there's no way she's
gonna do this and then
it switches the minute you walk out and
you're like hey everyone and you have
this confidence then after you're like
okay you know it's it's really
fascinating that i i also feel like you
can be like butterflies in your stomach
yeah do you feel that way oh yeah all
the time but you're right the minute you
get into that it's like you're on yeah
you're on it's almost you become that
second person right and then you throw
up afterwards yeah yeah after you're
left i need two glasses of wine i'm
ready to go where's my yeah exactly i
love this i love this okay so speaking
of what would you tell your younger self
just because we were talking about that
before yes he's saying this i love this
if i met my younger self i would tell
myself to invest now
i agree i also wish i had invested
earlier i do i like gosh it's so true i
like that all right